gate Crispin blunt who's one of the
first MPS to publicly call for Liz truss
to resign a Crispin blunt very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us so as I say one of the
first call for Liz truss to go so what
your reaction now that she's gone
well all the time hugely relieved uh
that we've got that issue out of the way
and we're now the president is selecting
a successor I just want to spare a
thought for uh lives in her family it
must have been incredibly difficult
um but what she hasn't yet shown is the
self-known issue of this process of
having put herself forward for these
responsibilities she's just made it
through the process
um and we've seen this uh rather
very difficult last six weeks but now we
can resolve that and move on
what do you say to those who today feel
that Liz truss has been let down they
might say that she's been subject to a
coup orchestrated against someone who's
just trying to do things a bit
differently
let's just put it
so simply so I'm afraid
Matthew Paris uh
she simply wasn't good enough to be a
prime minister and the absence of the
qualities that we could see where she
was found a very difficult to
communicate effectively and the rest
um all helped uh bring this
apprenticeship to the conclusion that it
did
so who do you think should take her
place now
my choice is now for Richie sunac
um I have wavered in the course of the
last week between Jerry huntson uh Rishi
sunak but they are the two characters
now who are plainly capable of being
prime minister uh Jeremy Hunts uh
picking up with the chancellorship and
in three days settling the markets and
the financial position of the United
Kingdom was astonishingly impressive
but as he
is not going to run then the other
candidate who is a figure who has his
qualities if not yet all of his
experience
um uh because Jeremy spent six years as
a health secretary and uh earlier uh two
or three years as culture secretary uh
Richie sunak is Head and Shoulders
ranked above the rest of us uh in terms
of his basic personal capabilities of
being prime minister and that's why he
would now be my choice he was an
outstanding Chancellor he brought in the
furlough scheme which as far as I know
was globally leading and I designed out
of his office
um this is a very very impressive man
and I think he has the seriousness of
purpose uh for the nation to listen and
to follow him in the difficult two years
we've got as we have to work through the
consequences of kovid uh the uh
consequences of standing firm the with
Ukraine which we must
um and I think he can bring not any the
conservative parties together he can
bring uh the nation together to address
the challenge that we face you think you
could bring the conservative party
together but there are a lot of people
very angry with him within the
conservative party they think he stabbed
Boris Johnson in the back I mean is he
really someone that can pull the party
together
well we're going to have to uh work
through the Johnson Psycho Drama I think
I was a supportive Boris right until the
end
um
and
I don't think we can go back there for
the next two years
uh and we need to put this contest now
uh where it sits and it's if you like
within the it's his story contest in two
years time we're going to face the
elections and we need to face the
electorate uh with uh two years of
restored sound Administration uh sound
finance and people being confident that
the conservatives can be trusted with
the highest office Boris Johnson has the
most astonishing set of skills there are
one or two weaknesses kicking around in
that personality and they were fairly uh
brutally exposed and amazed the subject
of all the controversy that in the end
uh led to him leaving office he is
probably not the character to restore
our reputation uh for the next uh two
years because of that uh controversy
however in the future beyond the next
general election
um as far as I'm concerned the question
is entirely open
but for now we need someone who is got
the proven personal capabilities of
being a prime minister
as well uh as then delivering uh the
kind of administration which in two
years time uh the country can make a
decision on uh having seen uh the values
and qualities of the conservative party
at their best in action
so you say he's probably not the person
to come in and pull the party together
but Boris Johnson would argue he's the
only one with a real mandate he won that
landslide in in 2019 that that big
majority he would say he's got a track
record of winning elections would you be
disappointed if he replaced Liz Truss
I I would foresee that we're going to be
probably straight back in the pickle we
were in uh when he left office and I
don't therefore think that's the right
route to take uh I want to escape from
that those uh those problems and I want
to present my party and my government to
the country in the best possible way in
2024 and I say that it's interestingly
because I will not be standing in 2024
and I think it's these two years are
really needed to uh deliver a really
good Administration lay the foundation
for getting out of the kovic crisis uh
for uh leading uh Western Europe and
contributing to the rest of the world
standing shoulder to shoulder uh with
Ukraine with the very serious security
threat uh that the Russians now oppose
to order uh they're at least in Europe
and of course the continuing rise in
China these are the issues that have got
to be addressed and Richie sunak is as
well placed uh to deal with those uh uh
Boris Johnson he spent enough time on
the international circuit uh for people
to have got to know him and He will
carry a proper Authority
and that is necessary over the next two
years
um beyond that let's see what happens to
the 2024 general election and for now
the labor party has got to address uh
the fact that their program was as thin
as Liz truss from Causey Crossings in
terms of detail and that didn't survive
that contact with the markets and
reality and this is an opportunity for
them uh to get their uh appeal to the
electorates and the basis on which their
gains of government in 2024 they will
start as all-time favorite uh okay
with with enough detail then to be for
them to be uh ready for office in 2024.
this this process will do favors for uh
for both sides
okay Crispin blunt we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed for giving us your views on the
steps ahead thank you